[Applause]
you do have the guts to go on college
campuses apparently they're outside
right now screaming Ben Shapiro to which
I say no thanks I'm married I did six
hundred officers to protect me at
Berkeley it's been an incredible year
for The Daily wire there's no such thing
as your truth right there's just not
truth and there is your opinion if it is
your truth I can immediately assume it's
there are two genders I don't
believe there 1,000 gender good for
Kanye West for at least beginning the
conversation we're not gonna know a lot
until he actually sits down with Putin
thanks for coming on the program thanks
so much thanks why in the world wouldn't
you our pants if they can ruin Brett
Kavanaugh by running roughshod over his
rights what do you think they'll do to
your rights
did you ever go on there on SNL yeah not
good policy one Republicans would never
lose so joining me is Senator Ted Cruz
listen let's talk about baseball or
something single motherhood has an
impact on girls but it has much more of
an impact on boys is your wife a doctor
so the rumor is that she is thank you
Ben Shapiro next meme
you
[Music]